Joel Schumacher also film did you ever
want to know how much of an ego Arnold
Schwarzenegger has his name appears
before the guy who plays Batman Batna
'pls and badass Batman logo makes a
record three appearances in less than 90
seconds DC Comics
asure I'm glad that Batman finally
decided to take everyone's advice and
put a disco in the hood of the Batmobile
this is why Superman works alone really
what was all that Justice League then
why would you waste money on bat shaped
embellishments that no one will ever see
I don't care who you are you can't do
that kind of blasting and massive
construction a tunnel this long would
require without permits and plenty of
people knowing about it while these
suits was facing another way when Mr
Freeze I skin' but I have a feeling
there were continuity errors in real
life on the set of this film The Iceman
Cometh compliant these guys keep hitting
mr. freeze in the back where he's got
all sorts of padding and they have guns
too but I guess those are four really
dangerous criminals they had no idea
this was a nice mission until
Commissioner Gordon told them on the way
here but sure skates also feet click
activations do any of these guys have
pockets on their outfits is there a rule
about not using your hands to carry the
gym what killed the dinosaurs is age
well I was gonna go with a meteor but
then I saw a Pacific Rim and they said
it was kaiju honestly I'm inclined to
believe anything at this point
since when does turning things to ice
instantly make them crumb loopy turns to
the laws of physics and says a hardy
even if you can steer straight rockets I
don't think you would steer them like
this I'm down with a nice gun I really
am but how could it possibly work in a
solid beam like this but still create
fine shapes like handcuffs shouldn't
Batman also have a string of ice across
his chest or face also seriously all
that and his goal was to put Batman in
ice restraints we saw this much ice
freezing the entire Gotham Police
Department a minute ago it's amazing
Batman didn't have heating gloves to
melt this ice but I guess they had to
make Robin not totally worthless somehow
and to blow up this rocket before it
turns Gotham and do it crater I want to
rock it the size of a car falling to
earth from 30,000 feet cause Gotham to
become a crater it's not a bomb it's
just a rocket I mean yeah few people's
houses when we smash but the city on the
whole has nothing to fear just a
question do you even need the door
panels underneath your feet if you're
just going to defy the laws of gravity
anyway this was a dated reference back
in 1997
so freezes escape plan was to turn his
car into a rocket launch out of the
museum through the tiny skylight climbed
to 30,000 feet and then exit the rocket
leaving it to crash and demolish all of
Gotham
while freeze gently glides back to the
same museum in the heart of Gotham
I'll kill you that's time why do
villains change their mind about killing
heroes right after a failed attempt to
kill them this wall is what should have
been around Batman after mr. freeze shot
his entire load of ice at him when he
was in the penis shop wow this laser can
heat an entire pool of freezing water
seems like this could have been used
against mr. freeze in the previous
battle somehow dr. Woodridge uh sleeves
being standing here expecting him to
stay and not kill anyone Gotham
University lab security video two years
ago what university keeps their science
lab security video for two years
how did Clooney ever see straight with
his head bobbing like this the guy looks
like he's in a constant audition for
night at the Roxbury you remember this
random fall when you were a kid that
doesn't even look like it hurt that much
you just became poison ivy like just now
how do you have an implicit partnership
with banal Rick even if you're free soot
can be powered by diamonds it's not
gonna just accept them being dropped
into a coin slot do you have any idea
how lasers actually work I'm beginning
to think this movie didn't have a
scientific adviser how in the world did
you manage to come here all the way from
England I wonder how you managed to lose
your British accent that your
prerequisite in this house a secret
niece who lives in England is not that
great of a secret there's no reason for
keeping the secret also is it normal for
students to continue wearing their
school uniform while on break especially
when getting on a plane from England to
the United States why would your mom
have signed a picture she gave to you as
peg why would your mom even bother
autographing a photo she gave you Wayne
Manor has to have like a hundred doors
on the ground floor does she really need
to risk her life climbing out a
second-story window with a rope made of
sheets and step on it how the hell does
Bane know where that place is even if he
wasn't a Dee angry thought brain has he
ever been there before they put a badass
telescope in the middle of a giant city
with bright lights that seems
counterproductive satellites already in
orbit allow us to reflect light from any
given point around the planet unlikely
four guards can't keep poison-ivy who
isn't using her powers or anything from
walking towards Bruges they just let her
come up here give verbal warnings and
follow her instead of you know taking
her arms and escorting her out Crusaders
are going to help us auction off a
prized diamond to raise money for Gotham
Botanical Gardens I know we need to set
up for the audience that Batman and
Robin have a Wayne related diamond event
coming up but why would Bruce invite the
obviously batshit lady who just
threatened everyone in the room with
plant-based world domination militant
arm of the warm-blooded oppressive if I
he didn't talk to herself so much we'd
never know what her plans are did Victor
freeze have somebody film his entire
marriage even when in closed quarters
how does he keep freezing people and
then taking the thing they were holding
without breaking off hands and arms
constantly
why do these guys out bidding each other
for different women it could have all
paid just ten grand and each gotten the
woman they were after seen does not
contain a left pocket even if the
pixie-dust had an effect on Batman he's
at least smart enough to notice that
she's blowing in his face for the second
time in five minutes right is that not
an immediate alarm bell poison ivy is
out of focus in this shot and it doesn't
feel on purpose also she's clearly
standing with her back completely to him
in this shot and her head turned away
and then when the shot changes
mid-sentence she's obviously standing
sideways seven minutes why does the car
have a sound effect
it's a fucking credit card are we
suddenly in a kung fu movie
also that credit card
freeze ridiculously ices down to old
people for no reason other than to show
he has an ice cannon on his car
Robin had no idea what to do with this
thing but there was a random henchman he
could make slippin halt so picking it up
was totally worth wants Garamond dust
designed to heat immense blood and don't
forget the ladies are Batman and Robin
still preoccupied with these henchmen it
can't be that many right commissioner
you have 11 minutes to follow these
people sure I'll just put them in my
thawing machine I carry around with me
Jesus Gotham has to be a nightmare to
get around it I wonder there's so much
crime in Gotham with a government that
spends all that money on King statues
just because you ice a giant statue does
not make it easier to run a car through
I'm pretty sure it's made of metal is
there some sort of gravity defying
aspect of these cars that I should know
about red birth control codes disable
engine yeah probably best to disable
Robins bike while he's speeding down a
giant statue arm rather than let him try
and make the jump that seems a lot safer
this refrigerator is not plugged into
anything
I guess it's visually appealing to drag
freeze into a cell like Hannibal Lecter
in a fridge but if it doesn't keep him
cold what's the point turned out to be
much more resistant to my love dust than
expected well no mr. freeze showed up
and kind of broke everybody from their
spell life or death will do that Robin
still wanted to bang you after all that
fighting though you didn't fail poison
ivy you just got unlucky he just called
me I mean I watched the scene several
times and no he didn't this article
underneath the crime watch for your
disbelief intention headline is about a
state sales tax so wait there's a garage
motion sensor activated but no other
alarms go off in the house what if
you're not at the computer when someone
breaks in do you not get one how much
coin to play oh come on
Coolio should have been mr. Freeze's
partner a right-hand man or something I
mean this movie is so filled with puns
why not that one come to think of it
where's the requisite cameos from ice
cube iced tea vanilla ice and all those
other ices that were in fear of a black
hat how did any of these racers know
where they're going
at least with Barbara they said she'd
never run this race before we know Robin
hasn't but everyone knows exactly where
all the turns are in the secret hidden
race course so this is where you hang
out but the details of how dick was
somehow able to save them both while
hanging by one foot from a metal rod or
completely unnecessary I've always
dreamed Alfred has supported me my whole
life and I'm gonna pay him back you
already had the money who needed and you
still went out and raced and possibly
died without giving him any money
beforehand
hey I said you got a visitor your sister
is here to see you
Arkham Asylum let's anyone in who claims
to be a sister and if she's using the
pheromone powder then why bother with a
sister lie at all this guard on the
right watches her blow mind control
shoot in the other guards face and just
patiently waits his turn instead of
thinking maybe something fishy is about
to go down it's ridiculous for the
criminal possessions Locker to have a
window and it's just so Bane can break
in and
we can have these Riddler and two-face
references what kind of cell opens from
the inside and prevents guards from
opening it from the outside has anyone
at this prison notified Batman yet about
the escape attempt in progress or did
they just run and grab a torch
how does freezing pipes create this big
of a hole in the wall to escape in fact
how does it create any hole for that
matter we got this off the Arkham
surveillance camera oh no you didn't not
a managed arter and people's photographs
are always taken when they walk off a
plane we all know this great leading
into the basement or whatever doesn't
really exist in this room it's
completely fabricated for the scene and
even if it did exist check out the floor
it's covered in icy mist no one is
watching anyone through this grating and
even if someone could don't you think
Batman would have noticed it okay so you
might not be able to breathe but I
highly doubt you know if your lungs are
freezing or not but thanks for the
update on your condition as it happens
why would freezes layer even have a
setting for heat now the guy dies if
it's just normal air condition
temperature why would he waste some of
the money he so desperately needs for
his research on building a heating
system that he will never use to freeze
villain crushes something at his hand
emphasize his determination cliche it's
staged one of McGregor syndrome oh no
cut down in the prime of his youth
Alfred can't just be dying of old age he
has to have some imaginary disease that
mr. Freeze's wife just happens to have
thank God mr. freeze was working on a
cure my family can be trusted
I'm family family cannot be trusted
good night
goodnight she also gets like unlimited
attempts to guess the password why is
the computerized voice saying the word
access quickly and normally when it
denies her but once she guesses the
super secure password correctly it says
the word access all sexual like mine
power of the telescope deflecting
crystals will complete my phrasing
engine yes even Bane is having a hard
time with stupidity of what Mr Freeze
just said friend partner brother will
you trust me now Bruce turns that you
don't trust me thing around on Robin
successfully without ever having had to
himself actually trust Robin thank you
holy
this telescope really has crystals in it
all place like a giant birth control
pill case I would love to know what kind
of images they're gonna get on this
thing if there are lots of this kind of
diamond out there why did the Gotham
Museum of Art have one sitting in a
glass case like it was anything special
he just thought of this plan to use the
crystals in the telescope for his ice
machine and yet this diamond engine
thing fits perfectly into the telescope
equipment what I'd like to help Batman
and Robin I anticipated you would would
and took the liberty to create something
in your size
when did Alfred have a change of heart
about Barbara doing dangerous stuff he
didn't even want dick to show her how to
ride motorcycles when she arrived since
when did he believe she was ready to
fight crime and that Batman and Robin
would accept her onto the team and how
did he know her measurements so well
also why go through the charade of
giving her a disk and telling her not to
open it if you would already built the
damn Batgirl suit this movie is already
over two hours long we don't need that
kind of unnecessary I'm down with a
female bat but for sure but why is this
the only bat suit without nipples sure
remove the rubber lips within kissing
distance of poison ivy also rubber lips
sure just push Robin in the moat while
you're in kissing distance of a rubber
lipless Robin
did Superman just go around the world a
hundred times to reverse Robin back into
this water why are the plants that have
been obeying her the entire movie
suddenly eat her just because she falls
on Batgirl just told Robin about freeze
his plan to freeze the whole city but
somehow Batman had already conveniently
come into the city on his bat
ice-skating boat and Robin on a jetski
wait are they wearing specially designed
ice ready silver-trimmed bat suits first
of all why second of all when the hell
did they change into those did they
bring those with them earlier before
they knew about friezes plan or weeks
time between taking out ivy and taking
out freeze to go home and change clothes
sunlight to reverse the freezing process
sunrise them for five hours here but
it's morning in the Congo if we could
relay the sunlight from the other side
of the Equator I'll take the satellites
about a minute to realign but yeah but
this is just an image of the Sun right
it's being sent by satellite with a
signal that generates an image
astronomers can see even if this
ridiculous telescope actually works you
can't really be mewar of the Sun through
this telescope can you I mean can you
she has special silver suits now - so
are we to believe that Alfred told her
never to listen to the CD that would
tell her about the Batcave and he not
only knew she'd do it and made a suit
for but also made an ice version in that
suit just in case
wait are you actually worried about
gravity this time I mean in this movie
it doesn't work right sure this is as
good a time as any for Bain to randomly
pop up just any old place what is even
doing this whole time
hey freeze the heat is on Batman says
the he's on and shoves a red gadget in
to freeze his suit suggesting it's some
kind of heater or a bomb but then he
just kicks freeze off the platform and
the red gadget is never seen or heard
from again look you can't tell me that
the telescope itself and then the super
race machine was powered by the crystals
and then half freeze fall and crash the
crystals but then still have the
telescope or time to relay the sunlight
to thaw the city why didn't all these
buildings crumble apart I mean in this
movie ice does weird things it could
destroy something completely like the
dinosaur at the beginning or sometimes
it requires something to be hid to be
destroyed this is incredibly convenient
ice when it needs to be lost freeze dude
you melted the ice off like two
buildings why would you stop to say this
telescopes gone there's no way to call
the city satellites could be positioned
to thaw the city directly oh come on
I mean suspension of disbelief got
destroyed in the first 10 minutes of
this movie now we're having to suspend
insanity too I think I would have
believed a giant hair dryer that warmed
the whole city before I believe the Sun
could be channeled into satellite beams
fortunately for all of Gotham City the
computer that controls satellites is the
only thing that survived complete
destruction of the observatory
as I told lady freeze when I pulled her
plug this is a one-woman show get the
gout you totally didn't record this and
definitely not at this angle you were
too busy cutting vines off with that
convenient bat saw remember so cue
Batman you there was no mother anway
recorded this I mean why does freeze
carry around the cure for a stage of the
disease his wife has already passed just
in case he bumps into someone while
stealing diamonds and freezing cities
who happens to have the stage one of the
super rare McGregor syndrome Batman just
gives a vial of random drugs from a
super villain to Alfred on the strength
of the super villains word they let
freeze keep his suit on in prison this
time and they put these two together
without restraints knowing full well she
killed his wife and he knows it
come on guy you need that bigger cave no
you are not that thing is humongous why
are they on the roof of the police
station at the base of the bat-signal
running away from the signal I mean it's
a cool enough looking shot I guess but
it's one of the least logical things in
this movie and that's saying something
I was hoping you'd drop it all too easy
or you won't be able to get a job
teaching high school chemistry chemistry
is is the study of change it is growth
than transformation telescope will give
future generations a chance to follow
their own stars
speaking of your parents were there like
I think they'd feel proud or concerned
that your attitude shows at best
pathological need for attention
worst psychotic death wish
this is my Max Headroom and what you're
about to witness is one of the most
sinister sounding intros to a trailer to
one of the greatest epics ever produced
it offered its me Barbara and afterwards
that is directly following I want to
talk to you about something even bigger
namely my Max Headroom
hey Killian
dear sub-zero now plane zero
he comes a son